Alles gut. Ich habe erstmal einige persönliche Daten.
Wie heißt sie?
Ich heiße Birgit Meisen.
Können Sie bitte nochmals langsam buchstabieren?
Ja. B-B-I-R-G-I-T-M-E-I-S-E-N. Wie Nordpol.
Birgit Meisen. Vielen Dank. Frau Meisen. Frau Meisen, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann genau geboren Sie?
Ich bin am 15.05.1970 geboren.
15.05.1970.
Vielen Dank.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Meisen?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter groß.
1,75 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 54,5 Kilo.
Alles gut, Frau Meisen.
Frau Meisen, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit zwei Wochen Schmerzen in der linken Leiste.
Und ehrlich gesagt geht es mir insgesamt ziemlich schlecht.
Ich bin total erschöpft und habe wirklich Angst.
Vielleicht ist es ja doch Krebs.
Warum denken Sie so?
Ja, lange geschlecht.
Frau Meisen, bitte versuchen Sie, ein bisschen ruhig zu bleiben.
Seit wann?
Der Arzt meines Vaters hat ihm gesagt, immer ruhig bleiben, positiv zu denken.
Jedoch ist er gestorben. Solche Denken hat ihm nicht geholfen. Herr Doktor?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Was haben Sie? Was hat Ihr Vater?
Er hatte auch Krebs. Er ist daran gestorben.
Können Sie mir bitte beschreiben, ob es eine Ursache dafür gibt?
Ich habe Krebs, Herr Doktor.
Aber jetzt bin ich nicht wegen Krebs, sondern wegen dieser Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Frau Meisen, wir können weiterführen.
Woher wissen Sie, dass Sie einen Krebs haben?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Vor etwa zwei Monaten wurde bei mir durch eine Biopsie die Diagnose schwarzer Hautkrebs gestellt.
Schwarzer vor zwei Monaten?
Ja, vor zwei Monaten.
Nach der Biopsie?
Ja, durch Biopsie.
Nach der Entscheidung.
Und heute haben Sie nur eine linken Seite Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Und wie gesagt fühle ich mich schlecht. Ich bin total erschöpft.
Diese Schmerzen sind plötzlich angefangen. Und seitdem waren Sie da.
Die Schmerzen strahlen irgendwo aus.
Ja, Sie sehen irgendwie nach oben in den Rücken und auch ins linke Bein, Herr Doktor.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Herr Doktor, wie kann ich diese Schmerzen einstufen?
Zum Beispiel auf eine Schmerzkala. Nur kein Schmerzen und zehn sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wie beschreiben Sie das?
Ok, danke Herr Doktor für diese Erklärung. Morgens würde ich sagen sechs von zehn.
Aber mit Ibuprofen vielleicht drei.
Nach der Ibuprofen Einnahmen?
Ja, natürlich.
Drei oder?
Ja.
Ja, drei. Drei, fünf, zehn, neun, fünf, zehn.
Gibt es noch eine Auflösung für die Schmerzen?
Herr Doktor.
Sie haben schon gesagt nach der Biopsie, aber links und links.
Nein, nicht nach der Biopsie.
Vor einem Monat wurden bei mir Lymphknoten dort entfernt und biopsiert.
Mit dort meine ich den linken Leistungsbereich.
Ja, wenn ich Ihnen richtig verstanden habe, vor zwei Monaten hat sich bei Ihnen eine Biopsie durchgeführt.
Ja.
Und vor einem Monat eine Lymphknoten entfernt.
Ja, Entfernung.
Und dann vor zwei Wochen links seitlich im Leistungsbereich Schmerzen.
Ja.
Alles gut.
Und vor zwei Wochen habe ich auch meine erste Chemotherapie angenommen.
Haben noch Ihre Akte dabei? Oder gibt es ein paar Ergebnisse dabei?
Nein, den Arztbrief habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Wie ist Ihrem Onkologen oder Hausarzt?
Herr Schumacher.
Alles gut, Frau Meisen.
Ich werde mit Ihrem Hausarzt und Onkologen in Verbindung setzen.
Mein Onkologen heißt Schumacher.
Ja, heißt Schumacher. Alles gut.
Haben Sie noch eine Behandlung bekommen bis jetzt?
Wie gesagt, ich habe meine erste Chemotherapie vor zwei Wochen erhalten.
Und ja, nur einmal habe ich Chemotherapie erhalten.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ja.
Erste Chemotherapie vor zwei Wochen.
Alles gut.
Und wann würde das Schmerzen angefangen?
Wie gesagt, vor zwei Wochen, Herr Doktor.
Nein, erste Chemotherapie vor zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen, ja. Gleichzeitig. Nach dem Chemo sofort diese Schmerzen.
Ja, die Schmerzen sofort angefangen.
Die Wunde im meinen linken Leistenbereich sieht noch nicht gut aus, Herr Doktor.
Alles gut. Ich verstehe, Frau Meisen.
Haben Sie aktuell im Moment Schwellungen, Rottungen oder Überwärmungen?
Im Wunderbereich gibt es ja.
Im Wunderbereich. Schmerzhaft. Gibt es Rottungen und Überwärmungen?
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie die Wunde, Sekret, bemerkt?
Das habe ich nie bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Entzündung bemerkt?
Vielleicht hat es sich entzündet, aber Sekret habe ich nie bemerkt.
Habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder phasenweise?
Seit zwei Wochen, wie gesagt, sind sie immer da, Herr Doktor.
Immer da.
Ja. Plötzlich angefangen und immer da.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden außer Schmerz?
Ja, ich habe noch weitere Beschwerden, Herr Doktor.
Vielleicht haben Sie Fieber, Luftnot, Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Schwedigkeit?
Bitte Schritt für Schritt, Herr Doktor. Ich habe viele Beschwerden.
Ja, ich kann sagen, aber ein bisschen langsam.
Seit etwa vier Wochen habe ich Luftnot, Herr Doktor.
Aber nur bei Belastung. Im Ruhig eigentlich nicht.
Ja, Frau Meisen, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Nachvollziehen.
Wir sind dabei für Sie.
Ja, danke Herr Doktor.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge und haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich fieberisch, aber ich habe nie das gemessen.
Nicht gemessen? Wir werden das alles messen.
Okay.
Kein Problem.
Fieberig.
Und ich habe auch Hübelkreis, Herr Doktor.
Hübelkreis.
Seit der ersten Chemotherapie leide ich darunter.
Erbrüchen dabei?
Nein, ohne Erbrüchen.
Dagegen muss ich Aldol tropfen, fast regelmäßig fünfmal täglich nehmen.
Alles gut. Dann haben Sie Herzklopfen?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Aber seit zwei Wochen, ungefähr jeden zwei Tagen, habe ich Nasenblutung.
Nasenblutung?
Ja, es dauert so 15 Minuten.
Gestern war sogar mein Kissen blutig.
Das kommt bestimmt von der Chemotherapie, oder?
Ja, kann sein. Nach der Chemotherapie könnte man Blutung haben.
Aber wir werden alles überprüfen.
Und dann haben Sie Luftnot?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Luftnot seit etwa vier Wochen.
Und dann? Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen? Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Beim Stuhlgang? Haben Sie noch Probleme?
Weil ich nicht so viel esse, muss ich auf der Toilette nicht so häufig wie früher.
Ja, ich verstehe. Wie ist Ihr Appetit in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich habe keinen Appetit.
Und in den letzten zwei Wochen habe ich ungewollt etwa vier Kilo abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilo? Könnten Sie bitte?
Vier Kilo.
In wie viel Zeit?
Innerhalb zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen? Ja, das ist zu viel, ich denke.
Machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Ich versuche, aber bitte glauben Sie mir, was ist sehr schwer?
Haben Sie schon beschrieben, nur haben Sie eine Nasenblutung?
Gibt es eine Blutung durch den Mund oder im Stuhl?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Alles gut.
Herr Doktor, ich kann nicht auch schlafen.
Ja, Sie haben auch Schlafstöße.
Mit diesen Schmerzen ist guter Schlaf kaum möglich.
Schlafstöße. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament oder?
Nein, ich nehme Halodon für Überleid.
Aber gegen den Zorn nehme ich nichts.
Außer dieser Krankheit haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Bei Ihnen bekannt?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Überkronik oder Superkrankheit oder Herzkrankheit?
Nein, wie gesagt. Aber das reicht, ich denke.
Ich verstehe. Frau Weiser, würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte vor etwa zehn Jahren einen Armbruch am linken Unterarm.
Linken Unterarm?
Ja. Der wurde mit Platten fixiert.
Und dann wurde er später wieder entfernt.
Erstmal Platten und Kifut und dann?
Dann wurde er später wieder entfernt.
Wie viel später? Zum Beispiel ein Jahr oder?
Wie viel später? Okay. Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Alles gut. Frau Meisen, haben Sie Allergien?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Nehmen Sie Medikament, wenn es für den Bebeidacht bedarf.
Außer Chemotherapie? Meinen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Wie gesagt nehme ich Ibuprofen und Haldol.
Haldol.
Haldol Tropfen.
Wie viel und wie oft?
Vier oder fünfmal täglich.
Alles gut. Frau Meisen, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nie.
Super. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Obwohl ich nie rauche, habe ich Kreuzer, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe einfach Angst zu sterben.
Bitte denken Sie immer positiv.
Natürlich, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Aber manche Zeit kann so sein.
Die Krebsursache ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Es gibt viele Ursachen für Krebs.
Herr Doktor, ich habe Krebs. Ich brauche keine Ursachen.
Ich habe schon Krebs.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Aber wir sollten immer positiv denken.
Ich versuche das zu schaffen.
Wir sind dabei für Sie. Alles gut.
Trinken Sie keinen Alkohol?
Ein bis zwei Gläser Wein selten.
Ein bis zwei Gläser Wein selten?
Ja.
Alles gut.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Frau Weisen, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und ich habe eine Tochter.
Eine Tochter, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ja.
Alles gut?
Ja, wir leben zusammen.
Ist Ihre Familie eine Erkrankung?
Zum Beispiel Vater und Mutter?
Wie gesagt, ist mein Vater mit 75 Jahren an Bronz-Schelkrebs verstorben.
Meine Mutter hatte vor einigen Jahren einen Schlaganfall.
Jetzt ist sie halbseitig gelebt. Sie ist auf den Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Können Sie erklären, warum meine Mutter einen Schlaganfall hatte?
Ja, für die Ursache gibt es viele Gründe.
Meistens eine Verstopfung im Gehirn oder einen Impakt im Gehirn kann Ursache sein.
Deswegen kommt ein Schlaganfall.
Okay, na gut.
Und was machen Sie, Birufli?
Herr Doktor, früher war ich Fachangestellt im Einwohnungsmeldeamt. Jetzt bin ich aktuell krankgeschrieben.
Einwohnungsmeldeamt, alles gut.
Frau Massen, meine Fragen sind fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Gibt es Hoffnung für mich, Herr Doktor?
Ja, natürlich. Es gibt immer Hoffnung für uns alle.
Gibt es heute viele Behandlungsmethoden, moderne Methoden, viele Menschen leben nach der Behandlung solange.
Brauchen Sie keine Sorge machen. Bitte bleiben Sie ganz ruhig.
Okay, ich hoffe, dass Sie mir geholfen haben.
Ich wünsche Ihnen sehr viel Gute nachvollziehen.
Ich werde mit Ihrem Stoff und meinem Oberspringen und dann werde ich Ihnen Schritt für Schritt Bescheid geben.
Brauchen Sie keine Sorge.
Wir warten Sie hier und ich komme sofort zurück zu Ihnen.
Okay, ich wünsche Ihnen viel Gute.
Danke für Ihre Hoffnung.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Doktor, es gibt so viele Fragen.
Leider ist es in diesem Fall wirklich so.
Du recherchierst die Tatsache der Medikamente und die Chemotherapie.
Es gibt viele Tatsachen, die möglich sind.
Wenn man sich wie wenn man sich die Frage stellen muss fühlt,
kann man sich zuerst sehr entspannt und kann die Frage nicht mit der Tatsache der Frage stellen.
Wenn man den Patienten sehr gut hört,
ist es nicht nötig, eine ganze Zeit für die Frage zu stellen.
Der Patient sagt es selbst.
Dann gibt es diese Fragen.
Du warst sehr entspannt wegen deiner Frage, Ekrem.
Du fragtest immer die Fragen, die du gefragt hast.
Du fragtest immer die Fragen in deiner Geist.
Ich weiß nicht. Und wenn Sie die gleichen Dinge ausprobieren,
dann ist es nicht so, dass Sie die gleichen Fragen ausprobieren.
Aber es ist immer so, dass man den Patienten hören muss.
Er sagt so viel.
Du musst keine Fragen stellen.
Du musst keine Nebenwirkungen lernen.
Du musst keine Wünsche lernen.
Wenn Sie 10-15 Fragen stellen,
dann ist es in der Zeit, in der Zeit, in der man die 5-Frage hat,
dass es genug ist.
Da ist es nicht wichtig, dass man in der Zeit nur auf diese Frage stellen kann.
Wenn du den Patienten gut hörst,
dann sind die Fragen sehr wenig.
In dem Fall sind die Fragen viel weniger wichtig.
Aber wenn du den Patienten gut hörst,
dann ist es in der Zeit in der Zeit,
in der Zeit, in der Zeit,
dass du den Patienten gut hörst,
dann ist es in der Zeit,
in der Zeit,
Aber nicht zu verspüren, dass du das erste Mal gemacht hast.
Und das erste Mal, dass du die Fragen über den Fall hast,
wie du es beantworten möchtest,
wie wir alle.
Das ist sehr natürlich.
Aber es ist schön, dass du es selbst bemerkst.
Wenn man es bemerkt, kann man es in der nächsten Zeit aufrufen.
Dann kann man sich warten,
um welche Frage ich fragen werde.
Du kannst es sich so ansehen,
dass du es dir bemerkst.
Aber du bist ein kranker Patient.
Aus diesem Sicht.
Zum Beispiel positiv denken.
Ich liebe das.
Ich liebe das nicht.
Positiv denken ist nicht positiv.
Das haben wir in der Psychologie schon sehr versucht.
Wenn man es so macht, kann man es nicht.
Oder wenn man es so denkt,
ist es nicht so einfach.
Anstatt davon, nur ...
Das ist nicht einfach.
Das ist eine große Frustration.
In diesen Patienten, in den Reaktionen,
dass du sie zumindest verstehst,
wie schwer es ist,
aber trotzdem Hoffnung ist,
dass es Therapie- und Möglichkeiten gibt,
werden wir gleich darüber sprechen.
Aber vier, fünf Reaktionen
müssen du dir geben.
Du kannst es in unterschiedliche Bereiche geben.
Denn dieses Patient
bringt dir eine Krebs-Krebs.
Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen, die Krebs-Krebs.
Und die Malin-Melone.
Wir können den Patienten nicht liegend sagen.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Deswegen müssen wir vier, fünf Reaktionen geben.
Du hast es natürlich auch gemacht.
Und wirklich ...
Wenn du mit diesem Patienten spielen kannst,
wie ich das Erfahrenkern von dir habe,
dass ich diesen Patienten nicht auf den Test habe,
dass er so sehr weiblich spricht,
aber immer mit der Hoffnung,
der Erschmerzen,
der Kanzler ist,
dass er nicht weiblich ist,
dass er keine Hoffnung hat,
dass er sich nicht weiblich fühlt.
Er bringt diese immer in die Gündung.
Wie du es machst.
Okay?
Obwohl er nicht weiblich ist,
bringt er diese Hoffnung immer in die Gündung.
Das ist das, was ich gelernt habe.
Das habe ich in Erfahrenkern gelernt.
Das ist wirklich, Herr Professor,
das Standard, das Positive, das Gleiche.
Du hast hier einen schönen Format gemacht.
Ich habe ihn auch schon gearbeitet,
aber ich konnte es nicht.
Ich kann diese Situation gut nachvollziehen
und verstehe, dass Sie seelisch und körperlich erschöpft sind.
Wir werden gemeinsam eine Lösung für Ihre Probleme finden.
Und sie dabei unterstürzen.
Es gibt eine schöne Sitzung,
die nicht ähnlich ist.
Eine sehr schöne Sitzung.
Ich habe versucht, das zu sagen, aber es ist nicht so.
Ich habe es nicht selbst gemacht,
aber ich habe eine lange Sitzung geschrieben.
Aber was habe ich gesagt?
Wenn wir hier die Reaktionen sagen,
ich möchte ihre Angst, ich möchte ihre Situation,
ich möchte ihre Frustration.
Was habe ich verändert?
Ich habe die letzten Wörter verändert.
Ihr Angst ist vollständig verständlich.
Die Begegnung ist sehr normal.
Ihr Angst ist nachvollziehbar.
Das habe ich in verschiedenen Zeiten gesagt.
Und dann, im Vorfeld der Reaktionen,
habe ich die nächsten Wörter gesagt.
Die Medizin hat viele Fortschritte.
Und heute gibt es viele Therapiemöglichkeiten.
Zum Beispiel, in einem Ort,
wo man sich nicht erlaubt,
weil die Situation sehr ernst ist,
heute gibt es viele moderne Therapiemöglichkeiten,
die das Leben verlangen und die Leben qualifizieren können.
Ich habe das in einem anderen Ort gesagt.
Und zwar trotz dass ich cigare und alkohol nicht benutze.
Habe ich mir damit nicht
in NV applications total in B team auch im Griff?
Hast du schon so Worxinjac?
Ja, ich trotzdem.
Das muss man natürlich auch nicht sagen.
Das ist wirklich ein schreckliches Gefühl, nicht wahr?
Sie haben sich so viel auf ihre Lebensweise betrachtet.
Sie sind Krebs.
Es ist nicht nötig, etwas anderes zu sagen.
Das ist hier schon genug.
Und dann geht es um ihre Frau.
Sie ist jung, klein, sie ist auch in der Hand.
Sie ist Krebs.
Sie ist hier auch in der Hand.
Sie fragt sich, ob sie sich unterstützen kann.
Sie sagt, dass sie nicht in der Hand sein können.
Ich sage es hier auch so.
Sie sagen, dass sie nicht in der Hand sein können.
Aber sie sind in der Hand.
Ich sage es so, dass sie sich mit ihrem Kind und ihrer Frau interessieren können.
Ich sage es so.
Ich habe vier, fünf Krebs, die ich hier in der Hand sein kann,
für die Hoffnung, die Angst, die Krebs-Fürsicht.
Sie können auch diese drei Krebsen annehmen.
Ich habe es vorhin in der Hand geschrieben.
Ich verstehe, dass sie sehr körperlich und siehlich erschöpft sind.
Das zeigt auch eine Anleitung.
Sie sind weder bedenso nor ruhig verhüten.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Es ist nicht einfach, um das Krebs umzugehen.
Das ist so.
Das zeigt eine Anleitung.
Ich weiß, dass es eine sehr belastende Situation ist.
Aber sie sind nicht allein.
Wir tun alles, um ihnen zu helfen.
Ich sage es so.
Sie sind nicht allein.
Ich habe meine Reaktionen geschrieben.
Ich habe sie auf einer Seite geschrieben.
Kannst du sie auf der Seite der Gruppe beobachten?
Die Leute können sie sehen.
Sie haben hier schon die Äußerungen gesagt.
Aber das ist dramatisch richtig.
Ich kann sie falsch sagen.
Sie können sich von dort beobachten.
Was wichtig für diesen Patient ist,
den Krebs, den Angst, den Angst,
den Angst, den Angst und den Krebs zu verstehen
und ihn zu beantworten.
Wenn du den Patienten zu Beginn entspannst,
wird er sehr gut.
Es ist wichtig, dass du ihn zu Beginn entspannst.
Es ist nicht nur ein Teil.
Du hast den Patienten in der Zeit des Prüfens.
Wenn du ihn zu Beginn entspannst,
wenn du ihn zu Beginn beobachtest,
wenn du ihm zu Beginn beobachtest,
werden Sie ihm helfen.
Das ist so, wie in der Klinik.
Die nächste Phase ist auch leichter.
Deshalb ist Empathie sehr wichtig.
Ekrem, wenn du dich beobachtest,
können wir beginnen.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben,
möchte ich ihn vorstellen.
Bitte schön.
Es geht um Birgit Meister,
ein 56-jähriger Patient.
Er wurde am 15.05.1970 geboren.
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß
und 55,5 Kilo.
Schwer?
Schwer, ja.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns
seit zwei Wochen
links im Leistbereich Schmerzen vor.
Laut der Angaben,
die Patienten sind die Schmerzen
nach einer Biopsie plötzlich angefangen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10
mit Ibuprofen 3 von 0.
Nach der Angaben,
die Patienten,
die erste Chemotherapie vor zwei Wochen,
dann die Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen,
berichten über den Schmerz.
Sie haben eine Schmerzen-Ausgabe.
Sie berichten über den Schmerz.
Im Wundbereich gibt es eine Entzündung.
Die Schmerz sei immer da.
Die Beschwerden verschieben sich
und werden sich beim Liegen auf der linken Seite
nach Ibuprofen besser.
Die Patienten fühlen sich dauerhaft fieprig.
Sie haben Übelkeit,
aber ohne Erbrüche.
Seit zwei Wochen nach der Chemotherapie
hatte sie eine Nasenblutung.
Es dauerte ca. 15 Minuten und dann wieder weg.
Sie beschreibt auch eine Luftnot
seit zwei Wochen.
Luftnot sei zwei Wochen.
Sie beschreibt in Appetanz nach der Chemo.
Sie hat die letzten zwei Wochen
vier Kilo Ungewalt abgenommen.
Sie hatte auch Schlafstörungen.
Außerdem klagt sie über eine Schlafstörung.
Sie klagt über eine Schlafstörung.
Die BGT-Tibanein ist unaufällig.
Vor der Erkrankung hat sie keine anderen Beschwerden.
Sie hat keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Sie hatte keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Sie hatte schwarze Hautkrebs.
Haben Sie das schon erwähnt?
Ja, ich dachte, sie hatte eine chronische Erkrankung.
Aber während der Hauptbeschwerdeverstellung
haben Sie das schon erwähnt?
Ja.
Deswegen sollen Sie bei der Vorerkrankung
diese Krankheit erwähnen?
Ja, ich glaube, sie hat es schon erwähnt.
Sie hat es schon erwähnt.
Bei der Vorerkrankung
haben die Patienten zwei Orten Schwarzhautkrebs.
Was bedeutet Schwarzhautkrebs?
Malignus Melanon.
Als Medikament nimmt sie bei Bedarf Ibuprofen.
Wegen Schmerzen und Schlafstörungen
halbdolf tröpfeln.
Wegen Schlafstörungen oder Andere Beschwerden
nimmt sie halbdolf.
Was hat die Patientin gesagt?
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Ich schreibe nur halbdolf Tröpfeln.
Damals dachte ich, ich werde Fragen stellen.
Wegen Übelkeit nimmt sie halbdolf.
Sie hat es schon gesagt.
Danke für die Information.
Nikotinkonsum würde verneint.
Alkoholkonsum, ein oder zwei Flaschen Gläser Wein,
sehr selten. Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Der Vater ist mit 75 Lebensjahren
an Bronchialkonsum verstorben.
Die Mutter leidet seit zwei Jahren
einem Schlaganfall.
Sie ist in einen Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Sie ist ein Fachangestellter
im Wohnungsmeldungsamt.
Sie hat eine Tochter.
Ist sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Keine Allergie.
Sie ist keine Allergie.
Sie hat es gefragt.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an eine Allergie.
Hab ich das vergessen?
Sie haben es gefragt.
Sie haben es nicht vorgestellt.
Deswegen habe ich sie gefragt.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran,
ob sie allergische Fragen gestellt hat.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ich habe meinen Verdacht
auf unwünschte Nebenwirkungen
der Chemotherapie.
Ja, wofür spricht
das?
Das ist unerwünscht.
Und die Infektionen, die Depressionen, viele komplizierte Komplikationen.
Okay.
Die Schlagstörung.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, bei der meine Note immer Verdacht Diagnose nach direkt sofort Differential Diagnose kommt.
Diese Symptome, die für Verdacht Diagnose sprechen, nennen.
Alles gut.
Das ist eine positive Einfluss.
Danke für die Information. Danke für die Raten.
Und Differential Diagnostik kommen eine plastische Anämie und TVT in Betracht.
Weil können wir da eine Aufklärung machen. Vielleicht warum TVT und warum Displa.
Nein, Sie sollen nicht, aber wenn der Prüfer die Prüferin fragt, dann fragen Sie.
Deswegen bereiten Sie vor.
Alles gut.
Ich würde gerne eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Erstmal Wunderbereich. Wunderstelle ist sehr wichtig.
Gibt es eine Infektion, Schwierigkeiten, Rotungen oder sowas?
Beim Druck gibt es noch andere Befunde.
Darauf sollten wir achten.
Und dann die Patientin hat beschrieben, ein Atemnot wird noch düst.
Deswegen Oskretation ist sehr wichtig.
Und die Patientin erwähnt noch Herzklopfen und Übelkeit.
Herzrhythmus und Oskretation ist sehr wichtig.
Bauchuntersuchung ist wichtig.
Sie hat auch eine Nasenblutung.
Es gibt noch andere Beschwerden. Man sollte alles überprüfen.
Und dann ein Blutbild annehmen.
Blutbild ist sehr wichtig.
Neuron und Lebenswerte und Infektionsentzündungswerte und Herzensüme.
Und dann CAP und Prokaston in der Gerinnungsparameter.
Das sind sehr wichtig.
Dann einen Ultraschall durchführen.
Am Bauch und im linken betroffenen Bereich.
Linkseitige betroffene Bereiche.
Dann ein CT oder MRT.
Ich würde gerne ein hämatologisches und onkologisches Konsil anfordern.
Ich nehme diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und sofort zwei große Zugänge legen.
Dann Flüssigkeit und Elektrolyt-Substitutionen zuvor.
Und Nahrungsstoff zuvor.
Sehr wichtig.
Analgetik und Antiemetik ist empfehlung.
Und meine Empfehlung.
Das war's.
Okay.
Bei diesen Patienten denken Sie auf ein psychologisches Konsil?
Ja, natürlich.
Onkologisches, hämatologisches und noch ein psychologisches Konsil.
Anfordern.
Warum möchten Sie diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Das ist eine unerwohnte Nebenwirkung der Nasenblutung.
Luftnot.
Linkseitiger Bereich.
Zum Beispiel eine Wundeeinfektion.
Und Übelkeit.
Gibt es viele verschiedene Befunde?
Deswegen möchte ich diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ja, Sie können solche Antworten.
Aber Sie können auch nennen, dass die Patienten Nasenblutungen und Wundeeheilungsstörungen haben.
Wahrscheinlich hat die Patientin eine Pantstöpäne.
Wegen Chemotherapie.
Und ein Virus kann eine Virus verursachen, dass die Patienten sterben.
Deswegen ist es sehr wichtig, dass die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Eigentlich isoliert werden.
Ich bin ein Pantstöpäne.
Ich danke dir, dass du mir das Ganze ausgedacht hast.
Aber es gibt viele Reaktionen, viele Anmerkungen.
Es gibt auch sehr viele Fragen.
Ich werde jetzt alles erklären.
Das ist kein Fall.
Danke dir, Ekrem.
Heute war Ipek ab.
Bitte, Ipek ab.
Ich bin auf dem Weg.
Ich will nicht weg.
Okay.
Ich werde es versuchen.
Frau Oberarztin, haben Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Natürlich. Bitte schön.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Sie ist Birgit Meisen, 56 Jahre alt, geboren am 15.05.1970.
Sie ist 1,75 Meter groß und wiegt 54,5 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie kam zu uns heute wegen ausprägter Müdigkeit
und schmerzen am linken Seite.
Frau Meisen hat für zwei Monate eine Malignos-Melanome-Diagnostik.
Die erste Lesion war am linken Oberschenkel.
Vor einem Monat hat sie eine Lymphknoten-Melanome entführt.
Vor zwei Wochen hat sie eine Chemotherapie entführt.
Nach der Chemotherapie klagt sie über diese Beschwerden.
Ihre Schmerzen treten plötzlich auf und sind bewegungsabhängig.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10.
Unter Ibuprofen 600 mg täglich viermal liegt diese Intensität bei 3 von 10.
Sie hat Angst und klagt über Entzündungszeichen.
Sie fühlt sich fibrig und seit zwei Wochen hat sie Nasenblutung.
Sie ist in Apathens und klagt über Gewichtsabnahme.
Sie hat eine Schmerzbedingte ins Omni.
Sie nimmt nicht bei Bedarf täglich 4 Mal Ibuprofen und halbdol Tropfen.
Sie hat eine Schmerzknoten-Melanome entführt.
Sie hat eine Lungenkrebskrise.
Sie hat eine Anamnese.
Sie hat eine Verdacht auf Nebenwirkungen der Chemotherapie.
Sie hat eine Schmerzknoten-Melanome entführt.
Versorgung.
Versorgung, ja.
Und natürlich auch psychiatrisches Konsul verordnen.
Und, okay.
Du hast sehr gut gemacht.
Ich gratuliere dir.
Ja?
Du machst es gut.
Ja, natürlich gibt es ein paar grammatische Fehler, aber das ist nicht wichtig.
Hauptsache ist, versuchst du und du hast sehr, sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Hocam, Benden kesinlich besser gemacht.
Tebrik.
Estafla, wir vergleichen nicht.
Ja.
Ich bin nicht sicher, was ich immer fragen werde.
Wenn du in die Musik und Abkürzung kommst, dann immer das.
Dann sagt der Arzt, ich habe schon ein paar Schmerzen.
Super.
Dann werde ich das Schmerzen recherchieren.
Wie ist das Schmerzen?
Was haben wir in Schmerzen?
Was genau ist das Schmerzen?
Was ist das Schmerzen?
Ich habe das Schmerzen gefragt, aber er hat es mir gegeben.
Jetzt bin ich das Schmerzen recherchieren.
Eine Love Can't Be Up to You ist gemacht.
Warum ist das gemacht?
Dann sagt er, dass ich zwei Monate vorher das Melanon-Tanus für mich gebraucht habe.
Das ist für dich.
Dann habe ich ein paar Fragen über das, um zu zeigen, was ich mit dem Thema betrachte.
Wo haben Sie Schwerzes Hautkrebs?
Wo befindet sich das Schwerzes Hautkrebs?
Wo ist das Schwerzes Hautkrebs?
Das ist wahrscheinlich in einer Nähe, aber um das zu sagen, ist das ein Beschenkel.
Dann kann ich verstehen, dass das für das Erstehen oder das Schmerzen recherchiert wurde.
Dann habe ich das Schmerzen auch gelernt.
Wird das Schmerzen eine Therapie angefangen?
Ist eine Therapie für dich jetzt begonnen?
Oder würde die Therapie angefangen?
Ist die Therapie begonnen?
Dann sagt er, dass ich zwei Monate vorher Chemotherapie gemacht habe.
Das ist die erste Chemotherapie.
Wenn ich die Chemotherapie nicht mehr beobachte, dann ist die Chemotherapie begonnen.
Dann fragt man mich, wie oft man Chemotherapie machen kann.
Das ist immer eine Reaktion.
Ich habe die ersten Lymphkundungen und die Melanon-Tanus gefragt.
Was ist das für eine Therapie?
Wie viel Schmerzen hast du?
Dann kann man das auch fragen.
Hab ich die Chemotherapie schon mal?
Dann ist die Therapie angefangen.
Was soll ich sagen?
oder common Zurück, Iris Mertz.
Ah, danke.
Das können wir sagen.
Oder ihr müsst es nicht tun, weil ihr es schon erlebt habt.
Jetzt könnt ihr direkt über Aare gehen.
Ihr wart da schon.
Aber wenn ihr es unbedingt wissen wollt, könnt ihr es sagen.
Dann, äh, hier.
Sind Iris Mertz,
wird er jede Woche wieder weg?
Wir fragen, ob es immer wieder nicht so ist.
Dann fragt ihr, ob es mehr Aare gibt,
ob es mehr Wünsche gibt,
hier die klassische Frage.
Wünsche ich dir, dass ich es nicht mehr habe.
Aber wenn es nur noch eine Bechse,
ob es noch ein Faktor ist,
oder ein Lindefaktor,
dann fragt ihr das.
Dann habt ihr alle Fragen zur Aare.
Und dann sagt ihr,
dass es nur noch eine Bechse gibt,
die gleichzeitig aufgetreten ist.
Aufgetreten.
Ob es noch Blut gibt, ob es noch so und so gibt,
dann fragt ihr das.
Dann fragt ihr das.
Ich habe schon sehr viele Fragen gestellt.
10-15 sind vorbei.
Ich werde sagen, ob es noch eine Bechse gibt,
die gleichzeitig aufgetreten ist.
Dann fragt ihr das.
Das ist die Frage.
Das ist die Frage, die die Blutung genannt hat.
Dann sage ich ein paar Dinge.
Wie oft haben Sie Blutungen?
Wie lange dauert es?
Ein paar Fragen sind genug.
Dann sind Sie damit interessiert.
Dann sind Sie Gastrointestinensystem.
Dann haben Sie Blutungen.
Das ist der Blut.
Dann haben Sie Probleme mit Blut.
Dann haben Sie diese Fragen.
Dann haben Sie ein bisschen Apathie.
Manchmal kann man das so sagen.
Manchmal ist es so,
dass man nicht
ein bisschen Apathie hat.
Ein bisschen ist das.
Manchmal kann man das so sagen.
Aber wenn es schwierig ist,
brow noten.
Dann haben Sie Legenda für Apakosion,
hast du diese,
dann hast du das Blut,
oder sonst ein abnormales,
tippe Blut.
Und Grußkaum,
ist es wieder und das kann man
sogarточно ein bisschen
Ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, was ich tun soll.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, was der Patient mir sagt.
Ich habe dann die Frage gestellt, was er mir sagt.
Dann habe ich eine Liste in meinem Kopf.
Ich hoffe, dass ich es besser gemacht habe.
Die Reaktionen, die ich schon erwähnt habe, sind die wichtigsten.
Die Kämmerung kann in einer Art aussehen, dass der Patient nicht mehr in der Hand ist.
Aber es kann auch nur ein besonderer Tana sein.
Der Patient kann die ganzen Angelegenheiten nicht beitragen.
Aber ich habe die Differentialdiagnose von Wund Heilung Störungen und T-Faulty gesagt.
Ich habe die zwei Differentialdiagnose gesagt.
Warum sagt man T-Faulty?
Es gibt die Luf-Not.
Diese Luf-Not kann auch von Anämie aus ausgehen.
Aber es gibt die Luf-Not.
Es gibt die Lingenbereiche, die Endsund-Not.
Es gibt die Schwöhnung, die Rötung.
Dann gibt es die Kanzertanus.
Dann gibt es Biopsie.
Die Differentialdiagnose ist ein Risikofaktor für eine T-Fault.
Die Patientin bekommt einen bestimmten Niveau.
Deswegen ist die T-Faulty-Perspektive sehr hoch.
Ich habe die zwei Differentialdiagnose gesagt.
Es kann Metastasen sein.
Es kann Knochen-Metastasen sein.
Es kann Apelastikanema sein.
Es kann Chemotherapeut-Badding sein.
Wenn man die Zeit des Symptoms ein paar Monate lang verwendet,
wo würde man das schreiben?
Ich denke, das ist in den Erfahren falsch geschrieben.
Ich denke, das ist nach dem Chemotherapeut begonnen.
Aber immer ein Monat, das Chemotherapeut zwei Wochen vorher begonnen hat.
Da gibt es eine Verrückung.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was das ist.
Aber normalerweise würde ich das mit Schmerz,
mit der Schmerz-Basik, mit der Schmerz-Aufgabe,
mit der Schmerz-Aufgabe, mit der Schmerz-Basik,
das alles mit dem Schmerz-Symptom schreiben.
Deswegen habe ich die Symptoms ein bisschen verändert.
Normalerweise ist es die Tanalio-Biopsie.
Danach ist die Lymphenode,
also eine AvD3, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Jetzt gibt es beim Chemotherapeut,
wenn die Biopsy gleich angenommen wird,
nicht, denn die Worte sind nicht verwendet.
Die Neun-Aufgabe.
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin gestorben.
Und so denke ich, dass ich nicht geholfen bin.
Dann hat Ekrem abgegeben, welche Arten von Krebs oder welche Krebs.
So etwas hat er wohl gesagt.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, was Çetin abgegeben hat.
Wenn er das gesagt hat, dann hat er den Vater positiv gefällt, aber der Vater ist tot.
Aber warum er tot ist, ist nicht so klar.
Das ist für ihn nicht so klar.
Er hat seinen Vater verloren.
Darf ich fragen, warum er tot ist?
Dann hat er mir gesagt, dass es Krebs ist.
Wenn er dann an seine Angstsache spricht und ich noch keine Ahnung habe,
dann kann ich ihn nicht mehr beantworten.
Darf ich fragen, warum er an seine Angstsache spricht und nicht mehr an seine Angstsache spricht?
Das kann so sein.
Ich habe in dieser Stelle die Noten aufgenommen,
die Karte aufgenommen, und ich bin dort nicht mehr.
Jetzt gibt es hier ein paar Fragen, ich schaue sie an.
Dann wird der andere Grupp beginnen.
Ich möchte Sie kurz über den Sitz sprechen.
Willkommen, Osman Hacan.
Glückwunsch.
Danke.
Ich konnte zwei Tage nicht reinkommen.
Ich war im Rennweg.
Osman Hacan, fünf Minuten sind es.
Ein kurzer Zeit.
Hätten wir eine Entstehung bekommen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht ist das auch ein Grund für das, was wir hier machen.
Wenn wir bereit sind, können wir das machen.
Aber wenn es möglich ist, dann können wir es breiter machen.
Okay, ich werde morgen wieder hier sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das noch erinnern kann.
Ich habe jetzt eine Schrift geschrieben, die ich Ihnen sprechen werde.
Ich werde sie in die Gruppe schicken.
Ich werde es kurz und schnell erzählen.
Meine Begründung war diese.
Nebunverkungung von Schamotherapie.
Normalerweise ist es eine schwierige Begründung für mich.
Ich werde Sie in die Gruppe schicken.
Ich werde Sie in die nächste Gruppe schicken, Osman.
Kann das sein?
Ich hoffe, dass es so ist.
Das kann es sein.
Mein Patient ist nicht ruhig.
Ich bin am Anfang.
Wir sind in den Test.
Im Moment gehen zwei Tests an einer Stelle.
Ich denke, es wird eine.
Ich habe sogar gesagt, dass ich meine Termine nennen würde.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie Sie nennen.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Gruppen.
Ich war so überrascht.
Im Test war mein Patient ruhig, ruhig und müde.
Er hatte nicht viel zu tun.
Ich konnte nicht mit dem Namen auf die Nase nennen.
Aber wie meine Schwester gesagt hat, konnte ich es nicht.
Ich konnte das nicht machen.
Aber ich habe mit meinem Patient direkt in die Augen gefolgt.
Ich habe keine Fragen auf Karte geschaut.
Ich habe alle auf den Patienten geschaut.
Wenn es eine Karte mit einem langen Schreibwort gibt,
wenn es einmal passiert ist, dann würde ich es kurz und schnell erzählen.
Aber wenn es einen langen Schreibwort gibt,
wenn es einen langen Schreibwort gibt,
dann würde ich es kurz und schnell erzählen.
Wenn es ein langen Schreibwort gibt,
Wenn es einen langen Schreibwort gibt,
dann würde ich es kurz und schnell erzählen.
Ich bin sehr為 das nicht wahrgenommen.
Ich habe mit einer Al remnantschreitenden Infektion
Ich habe sie gefragt, was die Unterschiede zwischen den beiden sind.
Ich muss sie so kurz erklären.
Ich habe mir die Erlegerung als gefährlich gesagt.
Ich habe sie gesagt, es kann gefährlich sein.
Wenn es ungefähr so ist, essen wir etwas, es wird uns krank, wir werden insalliert.
Das, was ich gesagt habe, das ist es.
Dann habe ich sie gesagt, ich esse alles.
Das war so.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Vielleicht gab es diese Fragen, aber ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Besonders meine Zeit.
Ich habe die Zeit 20 Minuten lang verwendet, aber das ist so.
In der letzten Minute habe ich die Zeit genutzt.
Ich habe sie gesagt, ich werde sie und sie machen.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr verstanden.
Sie hat sie gefragt, was die Diagnostik ist.
Ich habe sie gesagt, ich werde sie und sie machen.
In der zweiten Hälfte habe ich die Wörter und die Schreibungen von die Wörter studiert.
Ich habe das vorher nur getestet und die Schreibungen von den Wörtern kontrolliert.
Aber in der zweiten Hälfte habe ich sie noch nicht verstanden.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
In der letzten Minute habe ich die Zeit genutzt.
Die Zeit genutzt.
Ich habe die Zeit genutzt und die Therapie geschrieben.
DasAmerican School
Ich habe die Zeit genutzt, die Therapie geschrieben.
In der letzten Minute habe ich die Zeit genutzt.
Sie hat die Zeit genutzt.
In der zweiten Hälfte habe ich die Zeit genutzt.
Die Zeit genutzt.
Ich habe die Zeit genutzt und die Therapie geschrieben.
Ich habe sie gefragt, ob sie die vorherige Zeit schon kennenlernen.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat sie nicht.
Sie hat gefragt, woher ich hergekommen bin.
Ich habe sie gefragt, wo ich an Ankara studiert habe.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie aus Istanbul hergekommen ist.
Ich habe dort gearbeitet.
Sie hat mir die Gespräche mit Sumerianer gemacht.
Sie hat mich gefragt, welche Börse ich anesthetisch machen soll.
Ich habe sie gefragt, weil ich in der Anesthetik gearbeitet habe.
Die erste Gespräche von Chef Arsene war, dass er die Geburtstagszeit falsch geschrieben hat.
Er hat Oberarsen gezeigt und gesagt, dass er falsch geschrieben hat.
Oberarsen hat gesagt, dass er es richtig gesagt hat.
Das ist ein Gottes Lied.
Ich habe die Geburtstagszeit direkt gesagt.
Ich habe die Geschichten gesagt.
Ich habe das auch hier gemacht.
Ich habe das auch dort gemacht.
Aber Oberarsen hat mich gefragt, was die Geburtstagszeit ist.
Ich habe die Geburtstagszeit gesagt.
Ich habe das auch dort gemacht.
Als es um das Thema ging, haben sie gesagt, dass ich falsch geschrieben habe.
Sie haben es normalerweise richtig verstanden.
Das ist ein Gottes Lied.
Wenn sie nicht gefragt hätten, würde ich da etwas anderes sein.
Ich habe die Geburtstagszeit falsch geschrieben.
Oberarsen hat sie nicht geschrieben.
Ich weiß das von dort.
Das ist ein Kaba.
Dann haben sie mich nicht gefallen.
Das wichtigste ist, dass ich nicht von der Chemotherapie aus weiß.
Das ist eine Gruppe.
Jetzt kommt es.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie nur an der Progresse, an der Analysierung, an der Zuhörung geschrieben haben.
Aber sie haben auch die Thrombocytopenie schon sehr gut geschrieben.
Sind Sie hier, Abdo?
Ja, wir sind hier.
Ich bin hier.
Wo habe ich die Thrombocytopenie geschrieben?
Ich habe die Thrombocytopenie in der Differenzialdiagnose geschrieben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das geschrieben habe.
Ich habe das geschrieben.
Vielleicht hast du das wegen der Blutung geschrieben.
Nein, ich habe das geschrieben, weil es in der Differenzialdiagnose geschrieben wurde.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe das geschrieben.
Ich habe das Metastasform-Meringue-Melanome geschrieben.
Tia war für diese Begründung in meinem Geist.
Ich habe das nicht geschrieben.
Ich habe die Tf-Tem-Geräte von Tia geschrieben.
Und dann ...
Normalerweise wollte ich das Oberschreibungsschreiben,
als ich das Vakai vorgebracht habe.
Ich habe das nicht vorgebracht.
Ich habe die Antworten auf seine Fragen gegeben, aber ich habe das nicht vorgebracht.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass ich das Laboratorium aufschreiben sollte.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass ich das Schreibungsverkaufsbewerb aufschreiben sollte.
Ich habe das einzig aufgeschrieben.
Er hat mir etwas gesagt, wie Schemotherapie von Meringues-Melanome.
Aber wie ich es verstehe,
im Verkauf, im Verkauf,
ist es wichtig, dass du das richtig geschrieben hast.
Es ist wichtig, dass du mit ihnen gesprochen hast.
Ich werde das nicht vergessen.
Ich gehe mit diesem Kasten.
Das bedeutet, dass sie das weniger bemerken.
Und dann hat er gesagt, dass ich das Fatiguose-Syndrom schreiben kann.
Ich glaube, es gab so etwas.
Er hat gesagt, dass ich das Fatiguose-Syndrom schreiben kann.
Er hat das Meringues-Melanome-Metastasphäo-Syndrom erzielt.
Er hat das so gemacht.
Das hat sich mit der Medikamentierung zu tun.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, ob wir die Diagnostik besprochen haben.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, ob wir mit Oberhörsten gesprochen haben.
Ich weiß, dass wir nicht mit Oberhörsten gesprochen haben.
In der Therapie-Klasse wollte er mir die Isole-Oder sagen.
Er fragte, warum ich die Stationen so hochkomme.
Er sagte so etwas.
Dann sagte er, dass es ein Immunsystem gibt.
Er sagte, dass es ein Pancetophanis gibt.
Ich sagte, dass das Immunsystem weich ist.
Er fragte, was wir dann tun.
Ich sagte, wir werden es in einer Oder schreiben.
Er sagte, dass es eine Isole-Oder gibt.
Dann fragte er, was ich da tun sollte.
Dann fragte Schafferts etwas.
Ich habe meine Analyse geschrieben.
Er fragte etwas, aber ich wusste nichts.
Ich war auf ihn auf der Suche.
Ich bin hier nicht der Schaffer.
Ich war nur auf ihn auf der Suche.
Er sagte, dass ich nicht Onkologin bin.
Ich wusste, dass er mir eine Opioid-Methanologie erwartet.
Er sagte, dass ich eine Antibiotik geben kann.
Das gibt es auch in Erfarben.
Man gibt Analgetik, aber in der Boas
bekommt man 4x und 600 mg Ibuprofen.
Man bekommt 600 mg Ibuprofen.
Das wird weniger.
Was gibt es dann?
Opioid-Methanologie, Analgetik.
Das hat er nicht gesagt.
Er hat nicht gesagt, was er geben würde.
Er hat eine andere Worte benutzt, aber ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da sagen soll.
Er hat seine Aya nach dem Opioid-Methanologie bemerkt.
Er war eine gute Frau.
Er war die Opioid-Methanologie, die ich in der Zimmerung hatte.
Er war mein Prüfer.
Ich habe einen Prüfer gesehen,
der eine kaputte Frau.
Er war sehr gut.
Ein Mann sollte auch eine Frau sein.
Sie haben nichts zu tun.
Nein, nein.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Du hast die Informationen, die er und seine Frau verabschieden,
in die Teil 3.
Wenn du die Informationen von dir oder der Person,
die dich in der Prüfung verabschiedet,
kannst du fast alles verstehen,
ob sie dich verabschieden oder nicht.
Wie sie dich beherrschen.
Ich habe die erste Teil sehr gut.
Ich habe sehr ernsthafte Fragen.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, wo Maring-Melano war.
Das ist keine sehr ernsthafte Frage.
Aber die Abderabler können sich auf die Frage beachten,
um die gleichen Dinge nicht zu erleben.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe keine sehr genannten Details zu der Vorstellung.
Nein, nein.
Jeder war sehr wertvoll.
Danke.
Danke, Osman.
Ich werde jetzt etwas mit der Vorstellung aufschreiben.
Ich habe es vor ein paar Tagen gelesen.
Aber ich werde es gleich aufschreiben.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt,
dann würde ich mich gerne um sie beantworten.
Danke für die Vorstellung.